[Music]
I'm not be
prous I uh
um
anyway not being FES
for yeah I'm Dave rubben this is the
Ruben report it's October 3rd
2023 and oh my God he continues to break
down but we continue to build up we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals share subscribe to tap that
notification Bell and yes sorry to our
locals members that we did not have the
postgame show yesterday I had to jump on
to Megan Kelly's show that could have
sounded weird had to jump on to Megan
Kelly's show immediately after and then
the day went a little Haywire I will
make it up for you fine people today at
Ruben report. locals.com and the theme
today is rules for thee but not for me
that seems to be what is happening and
more and more people are seeing it that
sort of asym R depending on what side of
the political aisle you're on basically
if you're a Democrat if you're a lefty
or a liberal you get what I call
Democrat privilege which is basically
that you can break the law you can
destroy every Norm you can say whatever
you want etc etc and you can get away
with it and if you're one of the scary
let's say conservatives or Libertarians
or just an apolitical person who's been
mugged by reality just not a woke
leftist basically uh they're going to
come and get you so we're going to frame
this with a couple stories that are on
everyone's mind at the moment obviously
Trump and the case that's going on in
New York where now they're going after
his businesses and the whole thing is
just complete and utter nonsense and you
guys know I have hit Trump when I think
it's appropriate but I have no problem
whatsoever actually I'm proud to do it
I'm proud to defend the guy when he's
when he is uh when he should be defended
uh of course obviously I wish we had
more people that were calling balls and
Strikes honestly but I have no problem
doing that so I'm going to offer Donald
Trump quite a defense today uh we're
also going to compare uh the way Donald
Trump's being treated versus the way
Hunter Biden's being treated uh we don't
have to get into too much of that you
guys know how they've let Hunter Biden
slide and then of course Jamal Bowman
this uh this congressman from New York
who pulled a fire alarm to open a door
first time that's ever happened in
history uh you know that he's going to
get away with it too and the media is
running cover for him uh but I will
couch all of that within uh the fact I
would say the simple fact we're going to
play a couple clips from Tucker Carlson
uh that we are kind of in trouble it it
feels like everything is sort of shaking
there I know there's infighting on the
right there's the well there's the
infighting on the right the sort of
trump Dan santis infighting now there's
the gates McCarthy infighting there's
the just endless onslaught of nonsense
from the left and the security State and
big Tech all of this stuff but I do
think there's a way out and we are going
to share that with you at the end before
we get to it though let's talk about
moink box you guys know that 60% of us
pork production comes from one company
owned by the Chinese and their Hogs are
given something called ractopamine which
is banned in 60 countries including
China yet you find it in your grocery
aisle every day guys there's a better
way I want to tell you about moink that
is Moo plus oink moink delivers
grass-fed and grass finish beef and lamb
pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It Better
the moink difference is a difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farm stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like ribe eyes to chicken breast to pork
chops to Salmon plays and much more plus
you can cancel anytime Shark Tank host
Kevin o called Mo's bacon the best bacon
he's ever tasted and they guarantee
you'll say oink oink I'm just so happy I
got moed keep American farming going by
signing up at moink box.com Ruben now
and listeners of this the show get free
ground beef for a year that's one of the
best ground beef you'll ever taste but
for a limited time inkbox.com rubben
moink box.com rubben and now back to me
okay so let's just dive in because we
got a we got a dense dense Tuesday show
for you I promise you that much uh
Tucker Carlson who now is doing his show
on X which I guess used to be known as
Twitter or it's Twitter SLX or X Twitter
whatever it is Tucker is doing his new
show from home kind of doing the Dave
ruin model of all this doesn't need Fox
News anymore and he is Unleashed uh he
has gone out of his way to say whatever
he wants and people are responding to it
uh here he is detailing uh this Trump
Civil Trial so this is the Trump trial
related to his business practices and
New York state is basically trying to
make sure that Trump and the Trump
businesses can no longer operate there
uh Tucker had a good take on that
liberals have decided to strip Donald
Trump's name from the ballot in States
across the the country Trump is the
front runner in the presidential race
he's currently beating Joe Biden in the
polls yet liberals have decided that you
should not be allowed to elect him
president that's not democracy it's the
opposite it's
totalitarianism just this morning Donald
Trump appeared in court in New York in a
civil case brought by the state's
attorney general that was designed
explicitly to keep him out of the White
House that case is part of a larger
legal barrage against Trump that's so
far includes a total of 91 felony counts
every one of them politically
motivated but today's civil case is
especially absurd in fact it's hard to
overstate its Ridiculousness in some
Trump stands accused of inflating the
value of collateral Ed to secure loans
loans that he has already paid back with
interest for this non crime Trump and
his children are in the process of
losing their homes and their businesses
this is not a legal proceeding this is a
grotesque parody of the system that our
forefathers created the fairest in the
world that in the years since has been
seized by power worshippers like Arthur
and
Goran there there is so much here okay
so first off if the system most people
right even the people that are that have
turned on Trump for one degree or
another or frustrated with him related
to disantis or anything else they view
the attacks on Trump and the endless
court cases the federal court cases the
civil court cases ET they view it
clearly as a way to just destroy this
guy right destroy the movement behind
him and the odd thing about it is if
really the goal here by the system was
to ensure that Donald Trump does not run
for president or is too sidetracked or
confused or just doesn't have the the
energy to run for president because he's
dealing with all these civil and
criminal trials and everything else you
would think you'd at least leave him
with his businesses so this New York one
as Tucker points out is completely
ridiculous like if you don't want if you
want to get the guy on classified
documents and this and that and the
other thing I'm not defending it I'm
just saying like that's one way they're
going after him the least you would do
is say to him hey at least you can run
your businesses the way you've always
run them but now they're going after him
for inflating property values inflating
collateral on loans as Tucker pointed
out that he's already paid back okay
also by the way the idea that you can
just like inflate property values and
get endless loans is a little bit nuts
there are things called appraisers right
most of you anyone who's ever bought a
house and you have to get a loan on the
house it's 101 like you don't just
nobody just magically makes up the
number of the house the guy selling it
nor the guy buying the house right you
get an appraiser to come in he looks at
the value of house he sees what the
house is it old is it new how's the roof
what are the neighbors like what's the
neighborhood like what's the market at
right now what are the comps etc etc so
the idea that Trump could just go in and
just be like oh this thing's worth
anything and I'm just going to get the
loan for this blah blah blah but all of
that being said he already paid back the
loans with interest okay I also want to
address one other thing that Tucker hit
up top where uh he said that Liberals
are trying to remove uh Trump from the
ballot if he becomes the nominee uh
right now in Colorado New Hampshire
Michigan and Arizona there are there are
fights in all of those States related to
doing that uh if he is the nominee so so
we will see about that anyway it's just
another example of the system going
after him anyway if you want to see a
little bit more of the absurdity of
what's going on here uh there was a
camera in the courtroom yesterday and
check this out the video is from was
aired on Fox News this is Trump in court
and you're going to see the guy turn
around and just check out judge Arthur F
angeron at the end of this thing to be
or would they just be simply ushered out
when we're gabbled to
order well these the you're you're more
likely to have cameras and state
proceedings and so it's up to the
discretion of the uh judge uh and quite
frankly I'm not too sure that both
parties wouldn't want this I I think
that Trump views this the Optics of this
is working to his Advantage look people
looking at this live picture right now
uh will be either filled with Rage or
they will be thrilled and that's the
problem is that you know you have James
now being shown in the back you've got
Trump in the foreground and it fulfills
The Narrative on both
sides
oh look at
me did you get the selfie let's filter
that thing um the whole thing is absurd
the the analyst there made a good point
this is really all about Optics you know
Trump being there uh there is not one
Trump Bas person or it's not just it's
not just hardcore Trump magga Bas people
there's not someone who roughly supports
Trump who's looking at this thing like
now they got him this is the one they
got him on overinflating the price on a
property that he paid the loan back on
right it's just so absolutely absurd now
there might be some people you know
there's the endlessly obsessed with
destroying people type people uh
destroying Trump type people there's the
endless TDS type people that just love
more and more of this but those people
are kind of maxed out too right doesn't
it feel like we've kind of maxed out the
ride or die the man can do no wrong and
we've also maxed out the my God he is
the devil incarnate people and it's
everyone else in the middle that's
trying to make some sense of this but
here's Trump after the initial hearing
uh talking about sort of the general
absurdity of the charges against
him well I think that was very good that
last 5 minutes was
outstanding because the judge
essentially conceded that the such
evictions that we won at the court of
appeals is it a effect that therefore
about 80% of the cases
over I was going to come out and say
that as you know we're not entitled to a
jury which is pretty unusual in the
United States of America so you think
it's very unfair that I don't have a
jury but all right so what you got right
there was the best and worst of trump at
the exact same time because you got the
best in that he's fighting for himself
more people are watching that they kind
of see the judge you know and they just
see the farce of the whole thing but
then what Trump said at the end right
there was completely not true and I
don't know if he didn't know it was true
or he was lying or he's about to fire
his lawyer because it is not the case
that Trump wasn't getting a jury because
the judge decided something Trump's own
lawyer forgot to fill out the form he
forgot to put a check mark in a box and
that's why they are not getting the jury
we've got some info here from The
Business Insider Trump isn't getting a
jury in his 250 million civil fraud
trial because his lawyers failed to ask
for one former president Donald Trump
was entitled to receive a jury trial in
the New York civil fraud case and while
he himself wanted a trial by jury his
attorneys didn't correctly fill out
court paperwork okay it was literally a
box that had to be checked so now you
might wonder here maybe this is exactly
what Trump wanted uh he might have
wanted it so that everyone could point
to the judge at the end of this thing
and be like that guy just had it out for
Trump so in some way Trump saying he
wanted a jury trial but actually he
didn't because it'll be very easy if
this thing goes through and it's all on
one man to take him out Trump will have
all of his fire pointed on this one guy
on the other hand if he really did want
a jury trial and his lawyer literally
you can find it online like if they did
not check the box on the form and it was
as simple as that you got to fire that
lawyer uh this goes to something that I
think Trump is has long struggled with
which is that because of the way he has
turned on so many of the people look at
virtually everybody from the last
Administration right Kaylee mcin on down
virtually everybody right is an idiot
and a bird brain and a and a
sellout and blah blah blah uh you can't
you don't get the best of the best
working for you so it is I suppose
possible that his lawyer literally
forgot to fill out the form and he did
not know it when he said that or he
actually does kind of want this to
happen anyway he continued uh and I
completely agree with uh what he's
saying here about that this thing really
is just
a Witch Hunt so very simply put it's a
Witch Hunt it's a disgrace we have a
corrupt attorney general in the state
you see how she does this trial was
railroaded and FasTrack this trial could
have been brought years ago but they
waited till I was right in the middle of
my campaign the same with other trials
and indictments it's all run by doj
which is corrupt in Washington look he's
completely right about that the timing
of this in that most of the statute of
limitations on this has passed these are
old business practices that he's less
personally involved in the business
obviously than he used to be post
presidency and all that also the
businesses aren't as robust as they used
to be I mean I would love to know and I
don't know if anyone's done some full
research on this like a full audit of
the Trump organization I don't know that
it's for public consumption per se but
like how how much money are these
companies making are the hotel is really
doing well at this point the golf
courses the properties etc etc like
they're going after him obviously purely
for political purposes he links that up
not only to obviously the judge and all
and the corruption in New York but all
the way up to the attorney general
Merrick Garland and Merrick Garland was
on 60 Minutes and 60 Minutes as I as
Megan Kelly pointed out when I was on
her show yesterday it ain't what it used
to be uh and they asked Merrick Garland
if he's personally involved in taking
down Donald Trump you are not in
communication with the president or any
member of his administration with regard
to the investigation of former president
Trump no I am not if President Biden
asked you to take action with regard to
the Trump investigation what would your
reaction be I am sure that that will not
happen oh it's such an idiotic question
do you see how the mainstream media is
so ined with the Democrats Scott H there
is basically doing the work for him and
then he just has to say you wouldn't do
anything like that like look into Trump
in a weird way or exert any influence or
have any contact with the Biden
Administration to do any weird stuff
about the guy that might run against
your boss for president would you and
Merck's like
no thanks for asking the question dude
like it's just so insane but this is the
way the mainstream media frames things
and we know of course if it was the
other way around they would be framing
it completely oppositely uh so let's go
on to another uh
trial kind of non-trial Department of
Justice what the hell is going on here
situation and of course that involves
Hunter Biden uh this is video uh well
it's from the same interview on 60
Minutes and Scott Pell asked if Merrick
Garland has influenced the Department of
Justice in any way or if the Biden
Administration has influenced him in any
way as it comes to the hunter Biden uh
investigation you're not going to
believe his answer it blew me it just
it's going to blow you out of your chair
watch out hold on you are not
participating in those disc decisions no
Mr Weiss is making those decisions the
White House is not attempting to
influence those decisions absolutely not
great job Scott Kelly you wouldn't do
that would you you would have no
influence over the he's telling him what
the answer is as if the Attorney General
imagine if the Attorney General was
doing something the Attorney General was
one way or another like leading an
investigation or secretly talking to
Biden or you know secretly talking to
Biden to get rid of trump or secretly
talking to Biden to let Hunter off you
think he'd be sit on an interview and be
like yes actually you know it's so funny
you ask that question because I have
been doing that sort of thing and there
is this asymmetry Injustice I have been
doing it I just waiting I was just
waiting for somebody to say something to
me it's so idiotically stupid uh it
shouldn't be noted that of course Joe
Biden appointed meric Arland now that
doesn't that in and of itself does not
imply uh guilt necessarily related to
the job he is doing but it's just worth
noting uh anyway we've got a little bit
more uh from the daily wire on what's
going on at the Department of Justice at
the moment uh the Department of Justice
indicated that special counsel David
Weiss will soon be allowed to testify to
Congress about his investigation of
Hunter Biden the son of the president
Assistant Attorney General Carlos urate
sent a letter on Friday telling the
house Judiciary Committee that the doj
reaffirms its commitment to make Weiss
available to appear in the near term and
offered to make the US attorneys in
California and Washington DC available
for Testimony the Department of Justice
previously said in July that it was
prepared to Le uh to let Weiss testify
but then a plea deal in the case fell
apart after the plea deal collapsed
under scrutiny from a judge attorney
general Merrick Garland granted white
special counsel in August giving the US
attorney broader authority to bring
charges outside his own District now
what of course is this all about this is
about the hunter Biden laptop this is
about whether Joe Biden as vice
president and really even before vice
president was in essence selling
influence selling access was he helping
people who did not deserve to have jobs
say his crackhead son get jobs at places
like barisma a Ukrainian Energy company
and was he getting payouts for that
right that's what this is really about
now I want to flash back to Good Morning
America back in
2019 they asked Hunter Biden if he had
the qualifications to have that job at
barisma if your last name wasn't Biden
do you think you would have been asked
to be on the board of barisma I don't
know I don't know probably not I don't
know how would I know I was smoking
crack I didn't know what was going on
you have to understand he had no
qualifications zero qualifications in
energy in Ukrainian energy in
international relations he was a
crackhead okay and I'm sure there's some
functional crackheads out there I think
most of them are Democrats in Congress
right now okay but he he's saying it I I
don't know I I don't know I don't know
why would I get this job why else would
you get the job have any of you worked
for a Ukrainian Energy company nobody in
here has working for Ukrainian energy I
never get a call for from a Ukrainian
Energy company I'm probably more
qualified and I'm not smoking crack
maybe that's why I'm not getting the gig
anyway in that interview he continued
Hunter to say that really what this was
about it wasn't about him it wasn't
about the crack and the laptop and
giving money to the big guy and pedaling
influence and firing Attorney General in
Ukraine and any of that kind of stuff
for prosecutors in Ukraine it wasn't
about that it was about Rudy Giuliani
remember Rudy it was about Rudy and a
conspiracy to get Hunter do you regret
being on the board to begin with no I
don't regret being on the board what I
regret is not taking into account that
there would be a Rudy
Giuliani um and a um and a president of
the United States that would be
listening to this this
ridiculous conspiracy idea which has
again been completely debunked by every
no it hasn't been debunked it's been
bunked that doesn't really make sense
does it if something's debunked then is
bunk the opposite it doesn't sound right
bunk is the right way it was bunked like
it's true doesn't really make sense
though you wouldn't say that's been well
you get the point guys it has not been
debunked The Conspiracy Theory it turned
out not to be a conspiracy theory and it
was not debunked it was bunked somebody
has to look into that that doesn't
really make sense they have debunked the
debunking I guess that much would be
true uh but the point is oh he's like I
the one thing I regret is that Rudy said
made up some but of course Rudy
didn't make up some related to the
hunter Biden laptop he actually did not
he was willing to swear under oath the
Department of Justice didn't even want
to when he was trying to give them the
laptop they didn't even want to look at
it because they knew it was legit and if
it was in their hands they were going to
be in a whole bunch of trouble and by
they I mean the Biden family but let's
just look at how Hunter Biden is treated
versus how Rudy Giuliani is treated as
you know Hunter Biden is now invited to
the White House he got all new brand new
teeth because I guess when you're
smoking crack your teeth R away so they
gave him new teeth he's selling his
paintings for 500 Grand a pop he is a
shitty shitty ass artist but money
laundering is the easiest to do via art
right because art is completely
subjective
so we're selling this 25 G's we're we're
selling this tonight here there you
go Dave Rubin signed 25gs that would be
a great way to launder money right if
you wanted to give me money but you
needed to do it outside of the system so
that I could do a favor for you using my
influence bada bing you got a Dave Rubin
original right there okay here we're
going to send this to one of the locals
members after the show um but they treat
Hunter very differently right he's now
making a ton of money selling his
shitty ass artwork and what did they do
to Rudy well Rudy uh you may remember
this I mean this is a really depressing
uh picture to look at Rudy Giuliani I
had interviewed him that was a little
just right before that because I think
this happened in August and I had
interviewed him right before I went off
the grid in July at Rudy who is such a
hero uh related to 911 and everything
else and you can think what you want of
him and all of the stuff uh but that was
obviously was not directly related to
the hunter Biden laptop that was related
to election denial and everything else
but the point is you get it there is one
set of rules if you are a Democrat
Democrat priv and there is one set of
rules for everybody else uh but let's
continue with that because mer Garland
continued uh and this is another he this
guy's deep remember Deep Thoughts with
Jack Handy on Saturday Night Live they
should do Deep Thoughts with meric
Garland because here he is saying that
no sure it appears that they're you know
deeply corrupt and politicized but don't
don't worry why would you worry about
that we do not have one rule for
republicans and another rule for
Democrats we don't have one rule for
foes and another for friends we don't
have one rule for the powerful another
for the powerless for the rich or for
the poor oh we just act like it but we
don't have the not we wrote those rules
down it's just how we behave duh I mean
this interview was so brainn numbingly
ridiculous it was just insane but that
is interesting that he's saying that we
don't have one rule for these people and
another rule for these people we treat
everybody exactly the same uh of course
in reality you all know that that's
completely untrue how did the Department
of Justice treat high-profile
Republicans uh with regard to January 6
check out this headline from daily wire
uh guy who wasn't even at Capital on
January 6 get 22 years in prison they
are referring to uh what's his name
Enrique tario who is the head of the
proud boys he was not even at the events
of January 6th and he got 22 years in
prison do you think that maybe without
even unpacking anything else about the
events of January 6th and whether the
feds were involved or anything else do
you think that maybe that was a little
bit politicized do you think the
Department of Justice maybe treated the
people of January 6th a little bit
different than say the BLM and antifa
rioter who were burning down stores and
you know committing arson and destroying
property and killing people I mean at
least one police officer was killed etc
etc so I think you see the asymmetry
here but let's go a little further with
the asymmetry because we didn't cover
this one yesterday and it's an important
story it's an important story that
perhaps is the best illustration of
democrat privilege that I could possibly
ever give you because a Democrat did
something illegal at the US capital and
I think he deserves 22 years in prison
just like that proud boy guy who wasn't
even at the capital because that would
be sort of an equal application of
Justice here we have a tweet here from a
pol a political reporter named Olivia
beavers uh news representative Jamal
Bowman Democrat from New York was caught
on camera pulling the cannon fire alarm
ofe ahead of his this motion to adjourn
the vote as Democrats tried to delay the
CR vote multiple sources tell me we have
reached out to him for comment we
haven't reviewed the footage ourselves
well
Hallelujah Olivia you are in luck lady
because there are cameras at the capital
and Hot Diggity Dog they took a picture
of Jamal Bowman pulling the fire alarm
uh no one else in the history of the
world has ever pulled a fire alarm to
open a door uh it says in case of
emergency only and you pull pull the
fire alarm you're not going to believe
this and I'm not a scientician but I've
been around the block when you pull a
fire alarm the fire alarm goes off it
doesn't open a door it doesn't open a
window it doesn't flush a toilet it just
turns on the fire alarm that's how it
works but Bowman is a Democrat and he
will skate by so here he is explaining
what he thought was
happening alarm was an
accident you know I don't know why this
has gotten so much attention I was
literally just in a rush to go vote man
that's all it was M are you of any
repercussions either from leadership or
from Legally from police I mean listen I
take responsibility for what I did you
know but like I said I was in the rush
to go vote and uh you know investigation
will will will sort everything else out
have you talked to Jeff about it oh yeah
of course it's St long how was that
conversation I got to keep that between
me and the leader so I'm not going to
share that publicly yo bro I was in a
rush man sure I pulled a fire alarm it
had nothing to do with opening the door
or anything I was just in a rush trying
to do my job I mean it's
just so ridiculous but nothing will
happen to him nothing will happen to him
and by the way like I'm not for throwing
the guy in jail but like something
should happen right it's the endless
hypocrisy imagine if one of those
insurrectionist far-right Republicans uh
imagine if Lauren bobert who enjoys
getting her boob squeezed had pulled a
fire alarm to open a door these people
would be running with this endlessly you
guys get the asymmetry and I I I know
that it doesn't just flip by us exposing
it but I think it is worth noting uh but
let's talk a little bit about how the
media covers for these people because
it's not just that they can do all these
things the only reason that they can do
it and get away with it is because
there's an entire media apparatus a
corporate media apparatus that is in
place to make sure they can get away
with this stuff here is video of the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC a Woman by the name of Jasmine
vuan uh here she is defending Jamal
Bowman there were some reports that
began to emerge about representative
Bowman who was um seen pulling some sort
of Fire alarm um in the kenon house
Office billing earlier today we got a
statement on that um saying Congressman
Bowman did not realize he would trigger
a building alarm as he was rushing to
make an urgent vote the congressman
regrets any um confusion just to clarify
some things on that because I know there
was reports are beginning to emerge no
there's a picture of it lady reports are
be it's it already sounds it couldn't
quite be true reports are beginning to
emerge but who knows about reports those
are scary things and then some sort of
fire alarm how many types of fire alarms
can you think of it's kind of the
standard the red box and with the thing
and you pull it like that's the one yeah
and that's the one that he pulled some
sort of fire he didn't know what he was
he had no idea what he was doing it was
a red thing and it said fire alarm on it
was some sort of something or other
anyway you see the way they run and then
of course she reads the statement
because what she really is is a press
agent right she's in PR public relations
for the Democrat Party she's not not
there to obvious she's on MSNBC she's
not there to report the news but
speaking of people that are not there to
report the news
Connor yeah we're going to the view
ladies and gentlemen here is whoopy
Goldberg explaining that she would have
done the same thing if you're not
sure then put it up for find out what it
was as opposed to just saying you know
you did this to do that because when you
people pull stunts I tend to think that
they they may be more full of it than
than he is you know people who pull this
kind of stunt who say and you only have
3 minutes to read it I kind of think oh
all right well maybe cuz I know I would
have pressed everything if you told me I
had to get in there I would have pressed
whatever I had to press get the door to
open cuz I knew you would expect me not
to be there to vote so you don't know
we'll be right back who
be you you you dard um even if
everything you just said there is true
and I think we can mostly agree that
they Rush these things through and
nobody reads them and Nancy Pelosi
remember Nancy Pelosi we have to pass
the bill so we can find out what's in it
even if all of that was true a fire
alarm doesn't open a door there's no
connection there's no electronic
connection between the fire alarm and
the door I would have been pulling
everything to open that door all right
none of those things work here's Sunny
hus and I I don't want to call it a
stunt yet there's going to be an
investigation I know Jamal and so again
I'm a little biased but the doors that
are normally open so that he could get
to the chambers to read Were Somehow
miraculously closed how did that happen
and so yes sometimes you're freaking out
and you're an elevator you're pressing
all the but you were saying I've been
going to elevators probably about 47
years of my life okay I have never
accidentally you actually you might
press the wrong floor every now and
again you know I travel a lot sometimes
I'm in hotels different hotels different
nights and sometimes I'm like I'm on the
third floor and actually the night
before I was on the fourth floor that
seems legit how often are you just
pressing button like a crazy person
figuring out pulling levers and pressing
butt these people are all completely
it's not that they're bananas though
right like they're not Banas they're
doing exactly what they are supposed to
be doing and the in some ways the worst
case uh the worst example of someone
doing exactly what they're supposed to
be doing is the pet conservative on the
view of course I'm talking to Alyssa
Farah they give her a cookie they pat
her on the head they'll turn on her and
Destroy her but listen to the way she
frames the guy who pulled the fire alarm
it's not nobody's alleging it nobody's
something like a fire alarm no none of
that is true a man pulled the fire alarm
we have it on photo photographic
evidence of it he admits it but listen
to how she frames
it okay so Democratic House member uh
allegedly pulled a fire alarm um he
claims that it was because he was trying
to get to the house floor I it see the
video seems to or pictures suggest
otherwise I think it was because the CR
came out and he wanted more time to read
the bill but rather again than Congress
passing a bill that would allow for him
to have more time to read it he
literally pulled the fire alarm it'd be
like if I was like didn't like the next
topic and I pulled the fire alarm and
ran out we just can't do that what's
absolutely ridiculous though is that
there's magga Republicans that are
somehow equating this guy doing this
infantile stunt with January 6 to my
knowledge nobody died because this guy
pulled that stunt to my knowledge nobody
was bleeding nobody was attacked because
of this you know I'm really trying to
reach my higher self these days I'm a
father now I'm trying to I'm trying to
get to a deeper spiritual place so I'm
not going to talk about Anna Navaro
today okay I'm not going to do it but
Alyssa you see what she did there it's
like everything at once they they
intentionally on one hand she's saying
allegedly it was done and then she
explains that he completely did it the
language they use language in a weird
way to keep everybody stupid
stupid but if you wonder uh is this any
different than than they might treat
someone else like you know they want
Bowman to get off right like
to they want Bowman to not be charged
let's say uh without you know absolute
evidence that he did something that
seems a little different than say the
way the media might cover a certain
orange person in the past the idea that
no person is above the law is a Bedrock
principle of American Justice no man is
above the law no matter what the crime
and I agree with you no no man is above
the law and no person is above the law
no one is above the law no one is above
the law no one's Above the Law no one is
above the law no man is above the law
nobody is above the law no one is above
the law no man is above the he has to be
held accountable he's not above the law
no one's Above the Law neither that nor
any other title put you above the rule
of law
well nobody's Above the Law guys they I
mean they said it so we're gonna have to
take out Bowman but I hate to tell you
guys don't hold your breath nothing is
happening to Bowman but now I want to go
full circle on today's show because I
started with Tucker offering a sort of
warning about what they are doing to
Donald Trump and why that is dangerous
and once again and and I say this spefic
specifically to to my audience who are
more in the magga camp still these days
uh I have no problem and I think you
should see that I have no problem
defending him when he is worth defending
uh but Tucker then later in that very
same episode link that to more broadly
what is happening to the country right
now what's happening to many Western
Nations all over the place we know all
of the awful authoritarian moves that
are happening up in Canada but there is
some seriously bad stuff happening here
I guess this you could call this a black
pill here's a here's a black pill from
Tucker Carlson so they've done
everything they can by legal means which
are in fact extra legal means if we're
being totally honest completely Third
World stuff to take the opponent out of
the race and they're still
losing so I mean I don't know what's
going to happen this is not going to be
a race between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump I would bet my beloved fishing
camp in Maine that that is not going to
happen that's not going to happen so
what will happen well I don't know one
of like 400 distinct other possibilities
I mean I just can't even you know pick
one by the way if it's Gavin news we all
should be very very concerned that guy's
scary and I mean it I mean it
scary yeah but that's a whole separate
conversation but the point is this is
this will be forced these issues will be
forced soon like in a
year and the road from here to November
of 2024 is going to be filled with
developments nobody in this room could
foresee I can promise you that
so it's about to get very serious for
sure miss you know it's only leadership
of the world at stake which is also by
the way we now know the most lucrative
possible political franchise in human
history so everything's at stake what
wouldn't they do what haven't they done
what might they do next let your
imagination run wild so the question the
only one that you can answer is how will
you prepare yourself for that so that's
what we call the black pill right the
black pill of of course is that things
are really out of control and they
seemingly will get worse the white pill
is the last line that he said What will
what will you do about it and I actually
believe that as crazy as it might get
right whether whether they push Biden
over and then the day after he's you
know sworn in once again they somehow
replace him with Gavin or whether they
get Gavin in first or they do some
trickery with Kamala or all the tricks
they could do or whether they put
whether or not I think Trump is the best
Republican to be president right now
whether they put whether they allow
Trump to run or whether they stole the
election or what all of those things
those are that's a lot of stuff that is
beyond your day-to-day life right you
can care you can fight you can wake up
you can do all of the things that I
always talk about on this
show but you can take a little more
power also within your personal life and
there's one thing you can do really more
than anything else and now dare I flash
back to Dave Rubin in April of 2020
doing a video for prageru entitled The
Bravery deficit because you do have some
power but you have to exercise it here's
the good news if you currently reside in
the United States of America you live in
the freest country in the history of the
world Beyond some basic limitations you
can do whatever you want and with hard
work become whatever it is you want to
be pretty great ain't it so why the long
face because you know that something is
out of whack you really don't feel free
to say what you want or share your truth
thoughts on Facebook or even associate
with those you'd like to and why is that
I'll tell you why because there's a mass
Affliction spreading throughout the
Western world it's called The Bravery
deficit people good people like you are
afraid to say what they think and
there's Little Wonder so what can you do
believe it or not the solution is not
that hard step one think for yourself
step two say it out loud don't take the
path of least resistance resistance be
better than those who would silence you
deplatform you and MOB you how just stop
being
afraid man we got to get that guy on the
show could someone reach out to him I
mean talk about somebody making some
sense over a serious you know course of
time it's all it's all there you guys
get it guys speak up share videos tell
your friends what you think like wake up
more people the thing might be nuts and
it might feel crazy and sometimes it's
exhausting to be in the fight all the
time but there are little things you can
do in your life to make it better and
maybe if we do enough of that as I
always talk about if we do enough of
that at the ground level maybe the the
top layer actually could be repaired but
if you're just waiting for the Savior be
it Donald Trump or anyone else it
probably ain't gonna happen that is the
truth all right guys my full episode
with Patrick Bet David our first live
in-person interview right here in the
new home studio is up across platforms
right now part one with Carl Benjamin
AKA Sargon of aod uh it's up on locals
the full thing and part one of course is
up on YouTube and Rumble uh if you'd
like to join us right now we will extend
the postgame show today for a few
minutes because I had to dip out
yesterday uh you can join us at Ruben
report. locals.com and you can also help
keep us independent and I'll just keep
telling you what I think and sometimes
people be pissed at me for it and some
PE sometimes people will dig me for it
it's all good it's all good uh please do
join us over there uh we leave you
you think it's worrisome that Joe Biden
might be president again we leave you
with Camala Harris see you and so I
think
about because think about
[Music]
it and every day then think about
this and you know when you think about
[Music]
it just think about
it and think about
it cuz just think about
[Music]
it think about
it
[Music]
think about
them and let's think about
[Music]
it I drink I eat and drink no for
[Laughter]
breakfast
[Music]